in the spring of
1905 a storm broke out in the mind
of albert einstein at least that is how
einstein himself described it later in
life
and the result of that storm of thinking
is the special theory of relativity a
theory
that completely transforms our
understanding
of space and time and matter and energy
i mean einstein
found completely counter to experience
that clocks in motion tick off time
at a slower rate he found that objects
in motion are contracted along their
direction of motion he found that clocks
that one set of individuals say are in
sync relative to each other
he found that if someone's moving
relative to those clocks
they would say they are not synchronized
and of course
he also found the most famous equation
in all of physics e
equals m c squared establishing this
deep
hidden connection between mass
and energy now you should say to
yourself
if there is such
a unexpected nature to reality that we
have
missed through our everyday experience
why have we missed it i mean why aren't
we aware
of special relativity right in our bones
and the answer to that is when we look
out at the universe we recognize
that there are a huge range of scales
that constitute reality and we
humans only have access to a very small
part of that totality so to give you a
feel for that
let's look at one axis a length axis
and if you look at the scales that are
out there in length atoms 10 to the
minus 10 meter viruses 10 to the minus 8
meters red blood cells 10 to the minus
6.
single celled organisms there we humans
are 2 meters
the earth 10 to the 5 meters solar
system 10 to the 13
galaxy and on to the observable universe
itself
a huge range of scales when it comes to
length
and we humans really only have direct
access through experience to a small
part of that and that's only the axis of
length
imagine we look at the axis of mass
there too we will find a huge range
of scales right so if we go back and
look at atoms
they weigh in 10 to the minus 26
kilograms
go down to red blood cells 10 to the
minus 15
humans well depends who you're talking
to but about you know 100 kilograms or
so
solar system on to the entire universe
the observable part
10 to the 52 kilograms a huge
range of scales in mass we humans
only have direct access to a small piece
of it
one more axis to look at is the axis
of speed so we humans we walk around the
world
at certain ordinary everyday speeds
sometimes you go into airplanes
but there's a huge range of speeds out
there the growth of human hair that's
pretty small
human speed typically space shuttle 10
to the 3 meters per second
speed of light that's a number that's
going to come up a lot in our discussion
10 to the 8 or so meters per second the
point
is in this spectrum of all possibilities
in length in mass and also in speed
we humans occupy a tiny tiny part
so our experience the experience that
has given us our
intuition is built up from
a very limited sense of what is
actually out there so our intuition
which really has come in some sense from
evolution right so
we evolved out there in the jungle
and our intuition got built up in order
that we
can survive the survival value of
understanding your environment is what
matters
we humans only have access to a small
piece of
the totality of what's out there and
therefore it would be
surprising if what we have experienced
really does tell us about the physics at
all possible scales in length
in speed and in mass and it turns out
that indeed it is the case that when you
look at extremes
of mass or length or speed the world
operates the universe operates in ways
that we are not accustomed to
if you are looking at extreme
say a very small size the new physics
that comes into play
is called quantum mechanics if
you are looking at extremes of huge mass
the new physics that comes into play is
the general
theory of relativity if you are looking
at extremes
of speed how the universe behaves
at very very high speeds then
it is the special theory of relativity
that comes into play
that is what we are going to be
discussing so in a nutshell
all of the discussion we are going to be
having here
is focused upon how the universe behaves
at very high speeds that is
the special theory of relativity
since speed is the fundamental
core of what drives the special theory
of relativity
let's start at the beginning and ask the
most basic question
of all which is what is speed well
we all know the answer to that but let's
get all on the same page
so if that car say has a speed
of a hundred kilometers per hour we all
know what that means
if we look at how far it's gone divided
by how long it takes it to get there
so let's say this is one hour journey if
it's going 100 kilometers an hour
we know that it will have traveled 100
kilometers
in that hour that's what speed is
so in essence speed is
nothing but distance that
an object travels divided by
duration now expressed
in that language speed might seem
like i don't know a kind of boring
concept a pedestrian concept why
concern yourself with speed the answer
to that
is clear if we recognize
that distance is a measure that has to
do with space
duration is a measure that has to do
with time so if we find
as we are going to find going forward
that
speed has unusual features when the
speeds involved get very big
near the speed of light what we really
will therefore be learning
is that space and time
have weird strange features that is
what we are after okay good
that's where we're headed let's start by
first thinking about the non-strange
features of speed the features that we
all hold in our intuition so what are
the basic features of speed
well first off speed is a concept
that even before einstein was known is a
concept that
is relative what do i mean by that
well imagine we look at this car say
it's going 100 kilometers per hour
what we need to say is 100 kilometers
per hour
relative to the road why
if that road is itself moving let's say
it's on a boat
the boat is moving then the car's speed
relative to the water is not a hundred
kilometers per hour
and if we zoom out and look at that car
on the surface of the earth and we
realize that the earth itself is
spinning around
the earth itself is going in orbit
around the sun
with respect to the frame of reference
our perspective
right now that car is executing a pretty
complicated motion not just 100
kilometers per hour
so it's always vital when you're talking
about
speed to recognize that you can only
ever
frame the idea of speed for ordinary
objects that we encounter as the object
has
this and that speed relative to this or
that
object you need to specify the reference
in order that the speed that you are
specifying
has any meaning at all okay so that's a
very
basic feature of speed that it is
relative
another basic feature of speed is that
it is
additive and subtractive so
what do i mean by that well let's
imagine
that we have two characters
who are playing a game
of catch with say a football
george and gracie two characters that we
are going to encounter often in our
discussions
and imagine that they're throwing that
football back and forth
at say five meters per second now
that's all well and good completely
understood
but let's imagine that they go out to
play a game of catch on another day
and gracie is surprised to see that
george has a hand grenade
now she doesn't like hand grenades and
so she runs away when he throws it
because
she knows that by running away from the
hand grenade
she can change the speed at which it
approaches her
she can subtract her own speed from the
speed of the oncoming grenade
and that way have it approach her not
say
at the initial speed at which it was
tossed which for instance might be just
like the football five meters per second
instead if she runs away
at three meters per second she knows
that
now the grenade will approach her more
slowly
at two meters per second
and that is a good thing when it comes
to hand grenades similarly it's the case
that if an observer like gracie
is to not run away but say run toward
an object that is being thrown at her
the speed with which she approaches the
object will be added
to the rate at which it approaches her
so
if it was thrown at five and she's
running toward it at three
well we all know that that means
it will approach her at eight meters per
second
speed is additive and subtractive you
can change
the speed with which an object is coming
toward you
by either running toward it or away from
it
now let me quickly mention just as a
small footnote
these basic calculations that we've done
here
we surprisingly are going to find that
they
are only approximate when you take into
account
some of the strange features of
relativity but that's something that
we will encounter later especially if
you're doing the math version of this
course
but in terms of the basic idea that
comes from our intuition
you certainly would anticipate that if
you run toward an
object its speed will approach you more
quickly if you run away
from an object it will approach you more
slowly
third basic feature of speed that again
we are all familiar with is this
when you are executing a very special
kind of motion
what we call constant velocity motion
motion that has a fixed speed fixed
magnitude and a fixed direction
then you can't feel that motion right
you can't feel that motion
for a very good reason if you're
executing constant velocity motion you
are completely justified in claiming to
be at rest
and the rest of the world moving by
you in that sense constant velocity
motion is very special because it is
motion that is
completely subjective there is no
absolute notion
of being in motion when the velocity is
constant
so let me give you a quick example of
that so let's imagine
that we have one and the same
physical situation described from two
different perspectives so what i'm going
to imagine is
having george and gracie floating in
space
okay floating in space now here's
george's view of the events
he looks out and he sees a character
gracie coming toward him and she waves
as she passes
as does he his perspective is that he
is stationary and she is rushing by him
good now i'm going to show you exactly
the same situation
but from gracie's perspective so what
does gracie say
from her perspective she says that she
is stationary
out there in space she looks out into
the distance
and she sees george rushing by he waves
she does too and he goes on his merry
way is one perspective right
and the other wrong absolutely not
you are completely justified if you're
not
accelerating if you aren't changing your
speed or changing the direction of
motion
to say that you are stationary now
the reason why i'm emphasizing constant
velocity motion is something that you
have all experienced right if you are in
a car
and you take a sharp turn you feel your
body being pushed
this direction you know that you are
moving
if you are in an airplane and it's
taking off
as it accelerates as it speeds up you
feel yourself pushed
back into the seat you know that you are
in motion but if you're not accelerating
you don't feel the motion and in fact
there is
no way for you to detect
the motion at all so for instance if you
imagine
that george and gracie were in two
floating laboratories
out there in space and they do
experiments to work
out the laws of physics they will work
out exactly the same
laws because there will be absolutely no
remnant no experimental implication
of their relative motion if that
motion is at constant speed in a fixed
direction
no way to determine your
state of motion because you are
justified
in saying that you are at rest now that
idea
that idea that you can claim to be at
rest that there's no
implication of constant velocity motion
does not start with special relativity
it does not start
with albert einstein this is an idea
actually that goes
way way back it goes all the way back to
galileo
and galileo wrote a wonderfully
poetic description of this idea
let me show you a little visual
representation of what he said and i'll
just read his words too
while this plays so he said shut
yourself
up on a large ship and there procured
gnats flies and other small
winged creatures he said let a bottle be
hung
up which drop by drop lets forth its
water into another narrow neck bottle
placed underneath
then with the ship lying still observe
how the winged animals fly with like
velocity told all parts of the room
how the distilling drops all fall into
the bottle
place underneath then he says having
observed all these particulars
make the ship move with whatever
velocity you please so here it is the
ship is going into motion
and he says that so long as the motion
is uniform by which he means
constant velocity you shall not be able
to discern the least
alteration in all the four named effects
nor can you gather by any of them
whether the ship is moving
or standing still
that is the very same idea
that constant velocity motion cannot be
detected
it has no impact on your observations
old idea back with galileo so where then
does
einstein come into this story einstein's
new contribution
is to say that among the four named
effects
that galileo was talking about he was
just talking about
the gnats and flies and the water
dropping into the bottle place
underneath that those things would not
change
if you go into motion so long as it's
uniform
einstein added something to the list
einstein added to the list of things
that would not change
he added the speed of light
this is the surprising new insight of
einstein
let's see what it means
the speed of light is constant
right that is one of the most famous
sentences
in all of science the speed of light is
constant now
what does it mean and why should you
care
well to get there let's think about
how it is that einstein came to this
idea that the speed of light is constant
it's an interesting history where over
the course of many centuries
many people struggle to understand light
and perhaps a good place to pick it up
is in the
1600s to the 1800s when a whole group
of physicists spent a lot of time put a
lot of effort
into trying to measure the speed of
light and they did a pretty good job
romer huygens bradley fouseau foucault
these guys some of whom had very long
hair
made increasingly precise measurements
of the speed of light with
modern updatings we now know that the
speed of light is 671 million miles per
hour if you like those units it's
300 million meters per second or a
little bit more precisely it's
299 million 792 458
meters per second but we will round that
off to 300 million
meters per second for the most part so
that was good
people understood the speed of light
but even so physicists lacked an
understanding of what
light actually was and that's when
two physicists michael faraday and james
clark maxwell
who through experiments
mostly faraday through theorizing
mostly maxwell they realized something
quite amazing because they studied
electromagnetic waves they studied
ripples in an electromagnetic field
and came to a stunning conclusion so
maxwell
did this mathematically based upon the
experimental results of faraday
and roughly speaking what maxwell
ultimately concluded from the equations
from the math
was that an electromagnetic disturbance
always travels at a particular speed
regardless of the wavelength which is
the distance between
one crest and another and remarkably
the speed that he found for
electromagnetic waves again
independent of whether they have a very
long
wavelength or if for instance they have
a much shorter wavelength like this
fella coming in here
he found in the equations that the speed
of those
electromagnetic disturbances would
always be equal to a particular number
and that number
turned out to be 671
million miles per hour or 300 million
meters
per second so this was
a stunning insight and again if you
haven't studied
electromagnetism it doesn't matter all
that matters here is that
maxwell had these equations and from the
equations
out came from a calculation a speed that
was equal to the speed of light
what was maxwell to conclude well
naturally he said if the speed of
the electromagnetic disturbances
is equal to the speed of light then
light itself
must be an electromagnetic disturbance
it must be
an electromagnetic wave that
was a great step forward now we had an
understanding of what light actually is
but even with the progress that that
represented it still raised
a profound mystery and that mystery is
this
as we described before whenever you talk
about speed
you need to say an object has this speed
relative to that object you
need to state things in that manner for
speed to even have
any meaning right but when it comes to
the equations that maxwell was studying
they didn't specify what speed
671 million miles per hour was relative
to
right so if you have sound waves the
speed of sound is
relative to the still air if you've got
water waves
the speed of the water wave is relative
to the still
water what was the thing relative to
the speed of light was being calculated
nothing seemed apparent so physicists
dealt with this mystery
by making up an answer they said maybe
there is something called the ether
filling space and when you talk about
the speed of light
you're talking about the speed of this
electromagnetic wave
relative to the ether experiments were
done
to try to find the ether and to make a
long story short
no evidence for the ether whatsoever so
the puzzle remained this is where
the genius of einstein comes into the
story
because einstein had this uncanny
ability to look at something that
everybody else had been staring at
and see it in a new way and einstein
said look
if the equations are saying that the
speed of light is 671 million miles per
hour
but the equations are not specifying
what that speed is relative to
maybe that's because you don't need to
specify anything
einstein said the speed of light is 671
million miles per hour
relative to anything so long as it is
traveling
through empty space now
this is a strange idea
it is a maverick idea you might say it's
a crazy idea
because we are unused to any speed
that isn't relative we are unused to any
speed that for instance can't
be changed by running toward it or away
from it
but that is what einstein was saying so
let me give you
just a little visual example of what
this
constant speed of light this fact
that einstein was saying that you don't
need to specify
the reference for the speed of light it
is just
a number a law of physics here is what
that would imply so imagine we have
george and gracie out there again
gracie has a meter that can measure the
speed of light when she's standing still
george fires his laser beam and she gets
300 million
meters per second but now let's change
things just a little bit
and imagine that gracie runs away you
would think the speed should be less
because she's running away but no
einstein would say
it's still 300 million meters per second
it is a constant it is a
law of nature that the speed of light is
that number
relative to anything similarly if
gracie were to run toward george you'd
think the speed would go up
because she's running toward the
oncoming laser beam
no 300 million meters per second
again and the same thing would hold true
if it's not gracie that's running but
george so the source if the source is
running
you think the speed should be a little
bit bigger 300 million meters per second
not one iota bigger and similarly
if george were to be running away you
would think that the speed she should
measure should be smaller than 300
million meters per second
but it remains according to einstein
the same fixed number a constant
300 million meters per second
now if this is true right this is
einstein's idea
if it's true it's telling us as we
mentioned before
that speed has some very unusual
properties when you're talking about
speeds that are very fast near the speed
of light 300 million meters per second
or 671 million miles per hour is
very fast fast enough to go around the
earth seven times in a single second
but einstein is saying at those speeds
you begin to reveal a feature of nature
that you would not anticipate based upon
footballs or hand grenades or any of the
ordinary
objects of everyday experience so if
it's true
if speed has these weird features when
you're talking about speeds near the
speed of light
then that would mean that space and time
because speed
distance over duration space over time
it would mean
that space and time have weird features
that's why
this is such a critical idea but of
course the essential question is
is it right is the speed of light
actually constant
we care about the speed of light being
constant
because speed again is a measure of
space
per time so if speed does something
weird
then that must mean as we've emphasized
already that space and time
must be doing something weird too and
in this section we're going to describe
one of the most startling implications
of the constant nature of light speed
which is that
there is no universal agreement on what
things
happen at the same time that's where
we're going
now to get there let's start with
the basic intuitive understanding of
time
right so over the course of many
centuries
we humans have gotten pretty good at
learning how to measure time we have
developed
all sorts of clocks that through the
ages have gotten
better and better and better at
measuring the time
interval between one event and another
with absolutely astounding accuracy
now having said that we have still
struggled for
ages to really understand what time
itself actually is we don't
yet have an answer to that question but
we do
have certain basic understanding of the
properties
of time for instance we all agree
that clocks that are properly
functioning
and properly set all of those clocks
will tick off time
at the same rate so they will all be in
sync with one another they will all
agree
with one another we also generally agree
that individuals that are measuring the
duration
of an event with properly functioning
clocks will get the same answer we all
agree on how long it takes for something
to happen
and we all agree generally speaking
on what things happen at the same moment
right those are the basic features of
time as we experience
time in everyday life here
is the thing the constant nature of
light speed
says that all of that is wrong
it tells us that properly functioning
properly set clocks
do not generally agree with one another
it tells us
that we generally do not all agree on
what happens at the same
moment in time and we generally will not
all agree
on how long it takes for something to
happen
now those are some pretty striking
claims i'm not going to describe
all of them right now but we're going to
take on one of them
want to describe how it is that the
constant nature of light speed
ensures that different perspectives of
individuals that are moving relative to
each other will not agree on what events
happen at the same time and to do that
i'm going to
frame it in the context of a little
story
story goes like this imagine that there
are two
warring nations forward land
and backward land and they've just come
to an agreement they're ready to sign
a treaty except each president
stipulates that
he does not want to sign the treaty
before
the other so the secretary general of
the united nations needs to come up with
a plan that convinces them
that in the procedure that they are
going to use
each president will sign at the same
moment
here's the procedure that the secretary
general comes up with he says look
we're going to have you both sit at
opposite ends of a table we're going to
put a light bulb in the middle we'll
turn on the light bulb when the light
reaches your eye you sign the treaty
you're equidistant from the bulb
and therefore it should take the same
amount of time for the light to reach
you
you should sign simultaneously so here
is the setup the light goes off
the flash goes toward each of the two
presidents
hits them and they sign the treaty
and they are all very very happy
good now they are all very happy
that this agreement has been reached and
a few months later
they come to another agreement that they
again they want to sign
at the same moment except this time both
presidents want to do it a little
differently
even though they have many many
differences each of the presidents of
forward land and backward land they both
have a deep love of trains so they want
to do the treaty signing ceremony
on a train that is going right across
the border between
forward land and backward land so they
set up the same scenario
and here they are on the train
train is going along there is a table
again in one of the cars the presidents
are
equidistant on the train from the bulb
the bulb will be turned on just as in
the previous case
and when each president sees the light
he will sign
the treaty okay so here we go the bulb
goes off
the light flashes goes toward each of
the presidents
and they sign the treaty and everybody
on the train is again very very happy
with the result but here's the thing
just after they sign the treaty word
comes that the people on the platform
are fighting they're fighting because
those
folks from forward land claim that they
have been duped they claim that their
president from forward land signed the
treaty first
how could they come to that conclusion
well here's how it goes so the people
from forward land they are
on the platform watching this happen
and from their perspective look what
happens when the flash goes off
the president of backward land is moving
away from the flash from their
perspective
so it takes longer to reach him than the
president of forward land who's moving
toward the flash so let me show you that
again
watch what happens when the flash goes
off the president of forward land moves
toward the flash
president of backward land moves away
from the flash
the light has to travel further to reach
the president to backward land than the
president to forward land
it has the same speed the speed of light
is constant
so if it has to travel further it's
going to take longer to get there from
the perspective of those people watching
on the platform
and therefore they claim that the two
presidents did not
sign at the same moment they claim that
the president of forward land
signed the treaty first let me show you
one more variation
on that so you can really see the detail
of what's going on
this time i'm going to draw a line where
the flash takes place there is where the
flash
took place look how far the light has to
travel to reach the president of forward
land
versus backward land it only has to
travel this distance to reach forward
land
it has to travel this distance to reach
the president of backward land
light travels at the same speed if it
has to travel further
it's going to take longer to get there
so we now have an interesting situation
those people on the train are
absolutely convinced that the two
presidents signed at the same moment
those people on the platform are just
as convinced that they did not sign
at the same moment so the big question
is
who is right and who is wrong
and the answer is they are both right
the reasoning of each group of
individuals
is absolutely impeccable for those on
the train
the presidents are equidistant from the
bulb bulb
lights up the light travels the same
distance to each so they sign
at the same moment perfect reasoning
those on the platform they say
the flash goes off and it doesn't have
to travel as far
to present a forward land as it does to
the president to backward land
speed of light is constant and therefore
they do not get the flash
at the same moment that reasoning is
absolutely
impeccable so what this is telling us
is that the constant nature of the speed
of light
means that events which take place
at the same time from the perspective of
one group of individuals
will not take place at the same time
from the perspective
of another group of individuals moving
with respect
to them now this relies of course on the
constant speed of light
because what newton would have said is
he would say
the projectile say the light will get an
additional
kick from the train moving in this
direction and that additional
speed will allow it to cover this
distance
in the same amount of time the light
going this way
would have its speed diminished and
therefore it's traveling a shorter
distance
and when you take those two effects into
account
newton would say both of the presidents
get hit at the same time
regardless of your vantage point
but because of the constancy of the
speed of light we come to a very
different conclusion this is what's
known as the relativity
of simultaneity and is one of the most
startling
implications of the constant nature of
light speed
the relativity of simultaneity
strongly hints in fact almost
necessarily requires
that motion speed must be affecting
time itself the rate at which time
passes must be affected by motion that's
the only way that
we really can conclude as we have
already
that simultaneity depends upon your
perspective i mean in the treaty signing
ceremony
if clocks on board the train agreed with
clocks on the platform
then everyone would agree on what
happens at a given moment
everyone would agree on whether the
president signed at the same moment
but they don't agree and so clocks that
are moving relative to each other
must tick off time differently now
for us to make that idea
precise to us to really understand
how it is that motion affects the
passage of time
we need a way of measuring the passage
of time we need of course
a clock right now you can use
for all that we are talking about here
in relativity
you should feel free to use any clock
that you
like right your favorite rolex your
favorite grandfather clock
any clock that you'd like to use i
however
am going to make use of a special kind
of clock that's quite unfamiliar
but as you will see it's a very powerful
kind of clock for assessing the effect
of motion
on time so i should spend just a moment
addressing the issue of what is
a clock right so what is a clock a clock
is any
any physical system that undergoes
cyclical repetitive motion
and it does that cyclical motion it
undergoes those cycles
in a uniform way right so if you're
talking about
using the earth as a clock the earth
spins around its axis
in a uniform way and we use that to say
every time it goes around once that's a
day
we can talk about the earth in
revolution around the sun
right it does that in a fairly uniform
cyclical way
and we call each revolution a year and
on a more standard
wrist watch if you have well i should
say one of the old-fashioned ones that
has a
a second hand that's sweeping around it
does that sweeping motion cyclically
sweep after sweep after sweep and we
call each of those sweeps
a minute right so that is what a clock
is conceptually the new kind of clock
that i'm going to introduce
has that same kind of feature cyclical
motion a cyclical process happens over
and over again
but the process itself is a little
unfamiliar
because the kind of clock that i'm
talking about is called
a light clock what is a light clock
a light clock is a contraption in which
we have two mirrors
that are facing one another and a ball
of light will bounce in between them
and every time the ball goes up and down
you can think of that as tick tock
right tick tock the ball is just going
up
and down so let me show you a quick
visual of this
kind of clock this light clock there it
is so
every time it's going up and down let's
do it so it goes tick tock
tick tock it's regular cyclical motion
that you could use to measure how much
time elapses between one
event or another the reading is up there
at the top
of this light clock and what i want to
stress at the outset
is that this light clock however
unfamiliar it is right it is unfamiliar
you cannot go down
to walmart and buy one of these light
clocks
but conceptually a light clock is no
different from any other kind of clock
which means
any conclusion that we reach about the
nature of time
that makes use of this light clock as an
intermediate part of the reasoning
that conclusion applies to any
clock it would just be harder to reach
that conclusion
with a clock that had a more complicated
internal mechanism
because as i'll show you in a moment the
beauty of the light clock
is that because the mechanism the tick
tock mechanism is so
simple we can very easily
determine the effect of motion on the
passage
of time okay so to do that i'm going to
want to
introduce a second one of these light
clocks
because i'm going to want to compare the
rate at which time
elapses on one compared with the other
not when they are
stationary as they are here but i'm
going to want to
set one of them in to motion
actually before i do that let me let me
tell you
what you're going to see just to prepare
you because this is a great wonderful
result that we're going to find and i
want you to be fully prepared for when
it comes
imagine in your mind that i have one of
these light clocks okay
and i'm going to walk with it now it's
in motion from your perspective
think about the trajectory that the
light
will travel right from your perspective
the light will start here it hits the
top of the mirror here
and then it hits the bottom mirror here
so from your perspective
the light will have undergone a diagonal
up and a diagonal down
trajectory as i'm walking with the light
clock so i'll show you this in a moment
but let me just address one quick
question first you might think
well if you're walking with this light
clock with the two mirrors
won't the ball of light sort of miss the
top mirror because you're moving
as you're going along answer absolutely
not
what's the argument the argument is
simply this
from my perspective okay i'm
undergoing constant velocity motion
right
same speed in a fixed direction which
means
from my view i can say that i am
stationary
and it's you and the rest of the world
that are rushing by me
and therefore from my perspective it has
to be that the ball of light just goes
up and down and up and down because my
view i'm not moving
so the ball of light has to hit the top
mirror if it hits the top mirror from my
view it has to hit the top mirror from
you
from your view too the ball of light
cannot therefore
fly out into space so what therefore
would happen
is this let's put these two clocks
over to the side and let's look at that
ball of light
undergoing its motion in the moving
clock
diagonal trajectory up and down now
notice something
the amount of time that passes on the
two clocks is different why is that
well think about it look at the
trajectory
of the light in the moving clock
because it's a double diagonal going up
and down on the diagonal
the trajectory that it follows for it to
go tick and talk and let me show this
in slow mo the trajectory that it
follows to go tick and talk
is longer right so let's take a look at
that set these guys into motion
this guy has already gone up and down he
registers one
this guy because he's going on a longer
trajectory from your perspective
and yet the speed of light is constant
longer trajectory
it's going to take it longer to get
there which means this guy's gone
tick-tock
this guy has yet to reach the top of the
mirror so if we let this guy continue on
then notice that this guy is reached two
this guy
is just bouncing off the bottom he's far
away from reaching two
to let him keep on going and so on and
so forth
you see that the rate at which you've
got time elapsing on the moving clock
is slower than the rate at which time
elapses on your stationary clock and it
all comes down to the speed of light
being constant the perspective that
is from the laboratory observers those
folks who are
watching the moving clock rush by they
see that the ball of light
in the moving clock is still going
bouncing up and down between the two
mirrors
but from the perspective of those of us
in
the laboratory the trajectory which
the light needs to follow to go
tick-tock in the moving clock
the trajectory the path is longer
because it's going along this double
diagonal trajectory from our perspective
and if the path is longer but the speed
of light is the same that means
that the tick tocks happen at a slower
rate
in the moving clock our clock's going
tick tock tick tock
the moving clock is going tick tock
tick tock time itself
is elapsing slower on the moving
clock so this is this wonderfully
amazing idea that we have now
established with this light clock that
from the perspective of those in the
laboratory watching a moving clock
they will conclude that time runs slowly
on that moving clock and again
i've used the light clock as a tool as
an intermediate step
because as we just saw i can easily see
the effect
of motion on the passage of time the
same would be true if i used any other
clock a rolex a grandfather clock
because what we're talking about is how
motion affects
time itself and the conclusion
is that from our stationary perspective
a clock that's in motion
will take off time at a slower rate
we now know that time
elapses more slowly on a clock
that is moving relative to you and we're
going to
shortly calculate the rate at which that
moving clock
ticks off time compared to your clock
but first
i want to address two vital questions
to this issue of the slowing of
time and the first is
if you are moving with that moving clock
and someone on the platform watching you
says that your clock is ticking off time
more slowly
do you feel that time is elapsing more
slowly
and the answer to that is absolutely no
you don't because again it goes back to
that very same point that i stressed at
the outset right when we had
say george and gracie out there in space
so they're out there in space
and they were passing each other and i
emphasized that each could claim to be
at rest and that the other is moving by
them
right so that very same idea here we're
only talking about constant velocity
motion fixed
speed and a fixed direction that tells
us
that the person that you see moving
with that moving clock that person can
claim
that they are at rest and it's you
that's moving
so from their perspective time is
elapsing
as it always does if you will the light
clock relative to them is going up and
down and up and down
just as it always does you and the rest
of the world are rushing by them
so bottom line is nobody
actually feels internally
that time is ticking off more slowly
because of the fact that everybody can
claim to be the person the clock
at rest okay now that being said
if indeed you are watching a clock that
relative to you
is moving you should see that time on
it is elapsing more slowly if you're not
moving with that clock so the question
then is
why don't we ever notice that time
ticks off slowly on a clock that's
moving
relative to us why did it take the
genius of einstein to figure this out
why don't we know this in our bones why
don't we experience this in everyday
life
and the answer to that is the same
answer that we've come to
in analogous questions that we've
encountered earlier
it all has to do with the fact that
everyday experience
only taps into a small little
part of how the world is configured
and in this particular case everyday
experience does not involve us
watching objects that attain speeds near
the speed of light which is where these
effects
kick in maximally so let me just give
you a little demonstration where you can
see that idea in action so this here
is if you will your very own light clock
that you can play with on your own and
what you do with this light clock is you
set the velocity
of the clock at whatever value you want
and it's all in fractions of the speed
of light good okay now if you set the
speed of the clock to be relatively
small non-zero but relatively small
let's look at the rate of ticking on
that clock compared to
what it would be doing if the clock were
not moving at all and notice
that the diagonal path here has hardly
any diagonal to it
at all because the speed of the clock is
so slow compared to the speed of light
that light goes up and down
up and down with virtually no
ability for the clock to move to the
right during any of the tick tocks
so the motion of the clock has very
little effect on the passage of time
when the speeds are slow
but when the speeds pick up let's do
another version of this
let's put the speed i don't know 60 or
so of the speed of light
now the clock can move significantly
between its
tick tock because it's going quickly
it's going at a speed on par
with the speed of light half the speed
of light a little bit more and now
the diagonals truly are longer than the
straight
up and down and just to emphasize that
point maximally in this little
demonstration again play with this
here we are at 99.9 percent of the speed
of light
so if i now turn this fella on here
wow look at that look how far
it didn't even get to do its first tick
of tick-tock that's
how fast this clock was moving relative
to the speed of light
so whereas when it's stationary it would
go tick tock this one went
to didn't even get the k
of tick that's how far this clock moved
to the left because of its very high
speed so this clearly shows us
that again it is the speed of the clock
which determines the rate at which time
on it will tick off
more slowly than on a clock that is
stationary
that's the key point but we want to go
further because ultimately what we
really want to do
is to derive a formula for how much
slower
time ticks off on a moving clock
compared to a stationary one
and i'll derive that mathematically for
those of you who are taking the math
version
of this course in the next section but
let me
give you the essential idea here and
what is the essential idea
well the essential idea can be gotten by
a little bit of analysis on one of these
moving light clocks
so here is our little schematic version
of a light clock
that's in motion and if you think about
the process of going
tick-tock based on what we've described
that little demonstration
that we just did the key thing to think
about
in order to know how quickly this clock
will go tick-tock
is to look at the length of the
trajectory
so the light little photon if you will
starts here and in order to go tick it
has to travel that
journey and to go tuck it has to
travel that journey and since the speed
of light is constant
what is most relevant here is how long
that journey is relative to how long
that journey
would be for the stationary clock and
for the stationary clock it just goes up
and down
so if i just mark that for good measure
let's
give that guy a different color let's
call this guy
blue so if this length over here
is say equal to
l and this length over here
is equal to d then this one will be d
as well so this guy to go tick-tock the
stationary one
it goes up and down so it goes l plus l
it goes to l to go tick-tock on the
stationary clock
and on the moving to go tick-tock it's d
plus d
equals 2-d now again since
the speed of light is constant
this is telling us that the duration
for each tick tock
on the moving clock let's compare that
with the duration for this guy to go
tick-tock
on the stationary so that's the duration
of tick-tock on the moving
compared to the duration for tick tock
on the stationary clock
well that ratio is just the ratio
of the distances because the speed of
light is the same
so that's 2d over 2l which is d
over l so that is the essence of the
issue
tick-tock on the moving clock compared
to tick-tock on
the stationary clock is the ratio of the
length of the trajectory in the moving
clock from
our perspective watching it compared to
the length of the trajectory
on the stationary clock so that is
the key formula describing
the rate at which the tick tocks happen
on
the two clocks but now let me just take
this a little bit further
and note the following point which
easily can get confusing it's a very
simple point so if ever you find
yourself confused in this
calm down take a deep breath think it
through and you'll be able to work it
out which is this
if you're considering the amount of time
that elapses between two events right
if you're measuring the elapsed time
between two events on any clock but in
particular on a light clock
you want to know the number of tick
tocks that tells you
how much time has gone by now if
the duration for each tick tock is
longer
then less time will elapse on
that clock longer tick tocks
tick tock means less time will elapse
so what that means is if we are looking
at
not the duration of tick tocks but the
elapsed
time so the elapsed
time
on and i'll fill in which clock in a
minute divided by the elapsed time
here
and i'll fill in the clocks right now so
if the duration of the tick tock on a
moving
clock compared to the duration of
tick-tock on a stationary clock let's
say this is a ratio of
five to one that means that
five times more time will elapse on the
stationary clock where the tick tocks
are faster
compared to the amount of time that
elapses on
the moving clock so then this translates
into
the elapsed time on the stationary clock
compared to elapsed time on the moving
these are inversely related
to the duration of the tick tocks this
is equal to d
over l so again if this length
here is five times the length
for the ball to go up and down the ball
of light to go up and down in the
stationary clock
then that means the tick tocks are
happening five
times as slow in the moving clock which
means
five times more time will elapse on the
stationary clock compared
to the moving clock because the tick
tocks are happening
faster over here so that means that we
can now
take the little formula that we have
indicated over here and translate that
into the elapsed time in the stationary
clock to the elapsed time and the moving
clock
is the ratio of the length of that
diagonal
that we have over here to the length of
the straight
up and down so now we've basically
reduced
the calculation of how much
time slows on the moving clock compared
to a stationary clock to really
a bit of geometry geometry and
trigonometry and i'll show you how that
goes if you're taking the math version
in the next section but let me give you
the answer here is the answer
that we will establish if this clock
that we are looking at over here
let's say this guy has a velocity
that's heading over this way and
this velocity is equal to v
then that formula takes a speed v
as input and tells us how much slower
time elapses on the moving clock
compared to the stationary clock now for
those
not taking the math version of this
course this is one of only
two equations i'm going to show you the
other of course being
equals m c squared but this formula
is just as important as e equals m c
squared not quite as famous
but it tells us that the time that
elapses on a moving clock
is slow relative to that on a stationary
clock by a factor
of 1 over the square root of 1
minus v over c squared this
expression this little formula is so
important we give it its own name
we call it gamma again we'll derive that
in the next section but i just want you
to get a bit of a feel
for this result before we do that we are
going to
look at two clocks and one clock
you can imagine is here on earth
which we will call the stationary one
one clock
is on a rocket ship so now we've gone
from a train to a rocket ship
because we want some of these speeds to
be able to be really fast
and what this demonstration will do
it simply takes the formula the formula
that i have told you that we will derive
in just a moment so just remember what
that formula
is so this is equal to we claim
1 over the square root of 1 minus v over
c
squared the demonstration will take the
v that you
input into the demonstration
calculate that and show us the
amount of time that elapses on the
rocket compared to the amount of time
that elapses on earth okay let's do that
all right so let's be conservative at
first
i've chosen the speed of the rocket ship
to be
12 of the speed of light set this guy
in motion and you can begin to see
a bit of a time difference between them
it's hard to see but there is a bit of a
difference
but now let's crank this up
and let's go to 66 67
of the speed of light and now you
really can begin to see that the elapsed
time on
the rocket ship is less from the
perspective of those of us
here on earth looking at our stationary
clock
and let's then be inspired and you
should do this on your own
again to feel the formula this formula
for this object called
gamma in your bones i'm now at 95
i don't know let me push it all the way
let's go to
98 and a half percent of the speed of
light
and now you really begin to see
the difference between these two it's
dramatic here we are on earth
and hour after hour is going by in the
usual way
but from our view that clock in motion
time is ticking off very very
slowly so this factor
this guy called gamma this time dilation
as we call it kicks in substantially
for speed near the speed of light at
everyday speeds
time dilation is still there right so
this guy
over here where the velocity is in the
denominator
that kicks in at any velocity right
but that number is so close to one
for pedestrian everyday speeds that we
don't
notice it so clocks move around the
world all the time
we don't notice that they're ticking off
time at a different rate only because
that formula is such that gamma is very
very close to one so the ratio
of time on the moving clock to time the
stationary is
virtually indistinguishable from being
equal to one another
but the effect is there nevertheless
having said that let me just
emphasize one little loophole that we
will come back to it's kind of a curious
loophole which is that
if you have individuals that are moving
at relatively slow speeds
but they're very very very far apart
then that can amplify this effect so
there can be
big differences in time even at slow
speeds if you're talking about observers
that are very far apart in space
we will come back to that and it's
curious
implications as we go forward but
putting that to the side
if you're talking about observers that
are reasonable distances apart
distances that might be planetary scales
or even galactic scales it's only
when they're moving relative to one
another very quickly
that this time dilation effect kicks in
substantially
but it is there all the time so in some
sense we all
carry our own time this shatters
completely shatters
the oneness of time that newton
envisioned right
newton envisioned that there's one clock
out there in the cosmos ticking off
second after second
after second the same for all of us
this shows directly that that's not true
we each carry our own clock and our
clock ticks off time
at a rate compared to others that
depends on
the relative speed between us
i have been talking as though time
dilation
is an established fact regarding
how time itself behaves and
there's good reason for that right we
came to this idea
of time dilation based upon an
experimental fact that the speed of
light is constant
and then following in the footsteps of
einstein
we have parlayed that into an
understanding
that time on a moving clock ticks off
more slowly
than on a stationary clock good okay all
that's fine but
you know when you're talking about
an idea that is as strange
that is as counter to experience as time
dilation
well you just are happier you just are
more convinced if you have some
direct experimental support for that
idea
so the question is is there some direct
experimental support for
time dilation and there is there is a
lot of experimental support
i'm just going to give you two little
examples that really help
solidify the idea that this really is
tapping into the true nature of time
okay the first example is
look the most flat footed straight
forward way
of verifying that time on a moving clock
slows down
it is an experiment that was undertaken
in the 1970s
and what happened in this experiment is
very straightforward
scientists took two atomic clocks
they put one of those clocks on
an aircraft and the other atomic clock
they left
back on the tarmac they flew this plane
all around the world and they then
landed the plane ultimately and compared
the amount of time
on the moving clock to the amount of
time on the stationary clock
and lo and behold when they compared the
two clocks
they found that different amount of time
had elapsed on each in fact
the time difference between them is
exactly what einstein's
ideas predict it's a touch more
complicated to work it out
relative to the formula that we have
derived here the formula that we derive
this gamma factor
plays a part in the analysis but because
this plane is flying
around it's not at constant velocity
gravity comes into the story it's a
little more complicated
but it absolutely establishes
very directly that time on moving clocks
ticks off at a different rate and when
you undertake the detailed analysis
taking account of all of the
complexities that we're not going to
talk about
it confirms all of the ideas that we
have described
so that is look once you see that
these two clocks show a different amount
of elapsed time
you i would think should be convinced
that these ideas are correct
but nevertheless let me give you one
other piece of
experimental evidence that's sort of fun
and we're going to come back to it in a
little while
it has to do with a species of particles
called muons
you don't need to know what muons are
but they're very much like electrons
they're a little bit heavier
but the essential feature of muons
is that they are unstable which means
that they
disintegrate they fall apart in a
fraction of
a second which means that when these
particles are produced
as they are in the upper atmosphere they
can drop
down toward earth but at some point in
the journey
the particle disintegrates it falls
apart
into other particles it breaks apart in
essence
and the question is how far can
the particle travel before that
disintegration
kicks in and that's worth studying for a
moment
so the particle starts up here and drops
all the way down
to there and the issue is how far can it
travel before it breaks apart now
you all know what the answer to that is
it must be the case
that the distance it travels is equal to
the velocity times the time
and this time here is its lifetime right
how long it lives before it
disintegrates before it falls apart
into other particles now in the
laboratory
scientists have measured the lifetime of
these muons and it turns out that the
answer is 2.2
times 10 to the minus 6 seconds
and since scientists also know the
velocity that these muons have
in the upper atmosphere as they're
coming down they know how far
they should be able to travel and here
is the
remarkable thing when you do that
calculation
you find that the muon you would think
should only have enough time before it
explodes
to go about that far but observations
show that the muon goes much
further what's the explanation well
let's think about time for a moment
because this is the time as measured
in the laboratory
the muon is in motion right
that means that its clock is ticking off
time more
slowly which means that the muon
from our view
its clock is ticking off time slowly so
it should be gamma times delta t
as measured in the laboratory when it's
at
rest the way to think about this is it's
as if
the muon if you don't mind me putting it
in slightly violent language
the muon has a gun to its head right
and when a clock that the muon is
carrying ticks off 2.2 times 10 to the
minus 6 seconds it pulls the trigger and
it falls apart
but if the muon is in motion from our
view its clock is ticking off time
more slowly so our watch will have long
since gone by
2.2 times 10 to the minus 6 seconds and
the mu1 still will not have pulled the
trigger
because from its view that amount of
time
has not yet elapsed so what this means
is
that the distance d that the muon should
be able to travel
taking this time dilation into account
is now v
times 2.2 times 10 to the minus 6
seconds its lifetime
went at rest multiplied by gamma
so the formula then is 2.2 times 10
to the minus 6 seconds times v
divided by square root of 1 minus v
over c squared and it's that
formula this number is bigger than just
the product of the two things in the
numerator this fella over here makes it
larger
that explains that the muon can go all
the way from here to here
without disintegrating so let's get a
feel
for this result that muons travel
further than you would have thought
based upon newtonian reasoning because
of this time
dilation factor so this little demo
what you do here is you can choose the
speed of the muon
there in the upper atmosphere and this
will show
how far the muon travels before it
disintegrates so again
at slow speeds not much of a difference
from newton but then it really kicks in
with the vengeance at high speeds and in
fact this one lets you show the
newtonian answer
so that dotted line that you have
on the bottom there if you can see it
it'll be easier for you to see it on
your own when you play with this
so this dotted line is how far newton
would say
the muons will be able to travel before
they disintegrate so that's just
2.2 times 10 to the minus 6 times their
velocity but then if you take time
dilation into account
you see that the muons can travel much
much further and that's how we can
explain how they can reach from the
upper atmosphere
down to the surface of the earth where
newton would have thought they would
have
disintegrated way before they hit
earth's surface
so that gives us two strong pieces
of experimental evidence that
time dilation is real straightforward
direct experiments that can really only
be explained
by this idea that moving clocks tick off
time slowly
there's a wonderfully startling
implication of time dilation that
isn't often as fully emphasized as it
might
and i'd like to briefly describe it to
you now
it has to do with the following fact so
we know
from the formula for gamma that
the effects of time dilation only
really kick in in a significant way when
the relative velocity that's being
studied in a given situation approaches
the speed of light
that's all true but there is another way
in which the effects of time dilation in
which the effects of the
relativity of simultaneity in fact can
be
amplified over very large
distances over very large distances
these effects can become significant
even when the speeds involved are
ordinary everyday velocities so how does
this go
well to set it up let's first think
about
time for a moment from the perspective
of experience right so
we all generally think of time as a kind
of
continuous unfolding a continuous flow
but for the purpose at hand it's useful
to also think about time in a different
way is a
kind of series of moments
a series of snapshots one moment after
another moment
after another moment and any physical
process can of course be described in
this way a flower
a wild animal running moment after
moment after moment
horse running and so forth it's just a
series of snapshots that capture each
subsequent moment in time in fact you
can even
go out into space if you will and think
about the earth
in its orbit around the sun again moment
after moment after moment okay so
what i'd like to do is start with that
way of thinking about things and i'd
like to compare
my set of snapshots my
sequence of events that are unfolding
over time
and want to compare my snapshots to
somebody else's
snapshots who's moving relative to me
and to do that there's a related
idea that i want to introduce which is
the concept
of a now slice and by a now slice
what i mean is i consider the world
and i think about all things that are
happening right now
like the stroke of 12 on a clock or at
that moment
my cat jumping or perhaps other events
like
a bird taking flight at this very moment
say in venice or
we can go cosmic on this too so we can
imagine at that very moment
a meteor just striking the surface of
the moon or go even further away
we can imagine a supernova explosion
way in the far reaches of our galaxy
now a now slice is a slice
in this picture here where i put down
all those
events which i say happen at one moment
in time
and if i look at one now slice after
another
this is the unfolding of one moment
after another
after another so each of those events
that
lie on a given slice constitute those
things that i say
were real were happening at a given
moment
one now after another now after
another now there are
two points that i want to stress about
this we
give this picture a name that makes
perfectly good sense we call this space
time right because we have all of space
in each one of these slices imagine the
slice goes on forever includes
everything that's out there in the
cosmos at a given moment
and along this direction of course we
have the unfolding of time
so we have space and time that's where
the name comes from
second point is common sense
and everyday experience
would tell us that every
single observer in the universe
regardless of their motion
should agree on what is on a given now
slice that's the newtonian view of how
the world is put together
but when einstein comes into the story
that radically changes because with
einstein we have now
learned that the constant speed of light
means that observers who are in relative
motion
do not have the same sense of
simultaneity they do not agree
on what is happening at a given moment
in time and that has a startling
implication that i'd like to describe
and to do that
let me use a little metaphor here it's
one that actually i used
in my nova program fabric of the cosmos
if you've seen that but if not it's a
straightforward metaphor
think about this whole expanse this
whole space-time expanse
as if it's kind of like a big cosmic
loaf of bread
and what these now slices are i'm
basically
cutting this loaf of space time into
pieces which represent all of space at a
single moment in time from my
perspective
if someone is moving relative to me they
have a different perspective of what now
is what is simultaneous
and that means they carve up
the loaf at a different angle from
me so let me just show you that
schematically
so let me imagine i consider the
bird's eye view of that picture just
because it's easier for me to draw
and let me write down my now
slices in there so from the bird's eye
view
i will draw space at one moment of time
space at say the next moment in time the
next moment in time
and so forth so these are all my
now slices and just so that i have these
labeled in a way that we all understand
put it down here
going to the right in this picture is
what i consider the future
and going this direction is what i
consider the past
now somebody is moving relative
to me and let's say they are also
interested in drawing space-time
slices so let's draw theirs
and because they're moving relative to
me
they will slice up this
region of space-time at say a different
angle relative to me they slice the loaf
with a knife that's angled relative
to my slice because their notion of
simultaneity what's happening at a given
moment
say differs from mine now
if we are dealing and this is the point
if we are dealing with low velocities
the person far away has a low velocity
so we're not talking about velocities
near the speed of light
what that translates to in this picture
is that the angle
that we have here this angle
is relatively small
so in the vicinity of where that person
is sitting
low velocity motion has virtually no
impact
but the point and i'll show you an
animation of this in a moment is that
over
larger and larger distances let's say i
am over here and let's say somebody else
who's doing the moving
is far away over very large
distances a tiny angle can get amplified
into a very
large difference in time a very large
difference in our conception
of what's happening at a given moment so
let's take a look at
that idea in in animated form
let's imagine we are looking
at a big expanse of space and time
and we have a character an alien very
very far
away in space and we have
a more familiar looking character a
human being
sitting still on a bench over here now
if initially
these two individuals are not moving
relative to one another
they share the same idea of simultaneity
if there's no
motion so they slice through the
space-time loaf in the same way they
both
agree on what's happening at a given
moment
in time okay but now let's change
things a little bit let's let our alien
friend
hop on an alien bicycle say
and let's say the alien starts to ride
away
from me because of the relative motion
between the alien and me or the guy on
the bench
the alien has a different conception of
simultaneity a different notion of
what's happening now
and what that means is when the alien
slices up the space-time loaf
into all of space at a given moment the
now slice
the now slice will cut through at a
different angle
and again the point is small velocity
means small
angle but consider a small angle over
larger and larger and larger distances
between
us and that small angle turns into a
big change in time so in fact the aliens
now
slice actually sweeps in to
the past and it can be a significant
sweeping into the past when you put in
some numbers
as we'll do later on in this course you
find that the sweep
goes beyond when that guy was a baby
goes further
back in time than that and in terms of
events
on earth that the alien would claim to
be happening
right now from his perspective it might
be hundreds of years ago
say beethoven putting the final touches
on the fifth symphony now the thing
that's not completely obvious about this
and does take some mathematics and if
you're taking the math version of this
course
we will do the math if you're not taking
the math version i hope this is
sufficiently exciting that you might
take the math version of the course but
putting that to the side
why did it swing to the past and not say
to the future
here's a quick way of thinking about it
remember the treaty signing ceremony
president of backward land right
backward land was rushing away that
president
and he signed the treaty late right
he was not the one who did it first he
did it
second if you recall so in essence if
you are moving away
you are sweeping to the past you are old
news from that perspective
but that also means thinking now from
the treaty
perspective the president of forward
land if you are
approaching if you're going forward your
notion of simultaneity should sweep into
the future
and indeed that is the case so if the
alien
hops on the bike again but turns around
say and doesn't ride away from earth but
rides
toward the earth then indeed
the alien's notion of what's happening
right now on
earth does sweep from what we consider
to be the present
into what we consider to be the future
and might include strange things from
our perspective like this guy's great
great great
granddaughter maybe teleporting from one
place in the universe
to another so the point is
the whole notion of what you consider to
be
real what you consider to be taking
place right now
is totally dependent on your emotion
right so initially when the alien was
not moving say relative to us let's put
ourselves in the position of the guy on
the bench from
our view we agree with whatever the
alien says is happening right now
whatever's real
we totally agree right now when the
alien gets on a bike
we don't suddenly discount the alien's
perspective because he's on a bike
so if the alien then says that other
events
are considered to be now to be real on
his now slice
at a given moment we should accord that
statement the same status the same
believability
as when the alien wasn't moving relative
to us
so if the alien tells us that things in
our distant past
are real they are on his now slice at a
given moment
we need to take that into our
perspective on what's real
if the alien tells us that things in our
future are on his now slice at a given
moment
we need to take that into account too so
what this
collectively tells us is that the
traditional way that we think about
reality the present is real the past is
gone the future is yet to be
that is without any real basis
in physics what we're really learning
from these ideas
is that the past the present and the
future
are all equally real
time dilation is one of the strangest
counter intuitive concepts that you're
ever really going to
encounter and it's nice to have a kind
of
mental mnemonic a kind of shorthand way
of thinking about this strange idea
that perhaps makes it a little bit more
intuitive i'd like to
give you such an intuitive way of
thinking about time dilation now
and let me say you can justify the
explanation i'm about to give you
mathematically and if you're taking
the mathematical version of this course
we will justify it a little bit later on
but if you're not
don't worry about it but this gives you
a nice way of thinking about
why it is that time ticks off more
slowly when a clock is in motion here's
the idea
forget about time for a moment let's
just think about space
and imagine that we have a car that's
headed due north
at 100 kilometers per hour now imagine
that the car steers off and drives
to the east without changing its speed
now its motion in the northward
direction will not be as
quick as it was previously because some
of the northward motion has been
diverted
into northeast motion so what that means
is
motion can be shared between dimensions
and when motion is shared in that way
motion that
was fully devoted to one direction
gets diverted to another direction so
motion in the initial direction
slows down let me just show you a little
visual on that so here we have our car
i'm going to show three versions of the
car
one's going due north the others are
going northeast at various angles
and there you see the point this car has
traveled much further in the northward
direction
than these cars because these cars have
diverted
some of the northward motion into
eastward motion so the idea is
when you go in a different direction
through space
you divert some of your initial motion
into that new
motion in the new direction good okay
now let's take that idea and apply it
not to space
but to space and time okay so right now
here i am and you would say that i'm not
moving
relative to you say but of course i am
moving right look at my watch right my
watch is ticking
second after second after second taking
me
forward in time forward in the time
dimension if you will
good now imagine that i get up and i
start to walk
einstein basically told us that as i
walk
i divert some of my previous motion
through time
into this motion through space which
means i move through
time less quickly much as over here
this car goes less quickly in the
northward direction because it's
diverted some of the initial north
motion into east motion
when i start to move i divert my initial
motion through time
into this motion through space so my
passage through time
slows down that idea
to me is the most straightforward
intuitive way of understanding time
dilation
you can make it mathematically precise
but putting that to the side
if you want to think about why it is
that a clock slows when it's in motion
simply think to yourself when it's
sitting still
all of its motions through time when i
see it moving through space
it has diverted some of that motion
through time into motion through space
so it passes through time
more slowly that's why time ticks off
slower on a moving clock
the constancy of the speed of light
we've seen
in the context of all of the ideas of
special relativity
has a dramatic impact on our
understanding
of time it also turns out remarkably
that the constant speed of light has a
dramatic effect on space
and also on mass and we're going to talk
about both of those
but for now let's turn to the first one
the implications of the constant
speed of light for our understanding
of space so first is why
would we expect motion to affect
space well it's pretty straightforward
right because
speed as we emphasized is distance
divided by
duration which of course is space
divided by
time so if we learn
as we have that the speed of light is
constant
well we've also learned that time is not
constant so that means that space must
in some way compensate for the
non-constant aspects of time
in order that their ratio stays the same
allowing the speed of light
to be unchanged so in
schematic language in order to ensure
that the speed of light is constant
space must adjust itself in tandem with
time
so that the ratio for light stays fixed
so the picture you should have in mind
is something like this
if we consider that time is not constant
therefore space must change too
in relation to motion so that the ratio
space
over time is such that the speed
of light can remain unchanged
and what we'd like to do is take that
rough idea and make it explicit
we'd like to now determine what the
effect of motion
is on space how are we going to do that
well let's work
in the context of a concrete example
let's imagine that we have a train and
we want to ask ourselves
how would you measure the length of a
train
well that's a pretty straightforward
thing to do
when the train is stationary right
because if the train is stationary
you take out a tape measure and you
measure the length
of the train right so let's get things
going
let's imagine that that is the situation
and we're going to consider the length
of a train from the perspective of
somebody on
the train so that would be our fearless
train
rider george from his view the train is
at
rest relative to him so he pulls out his
tape measure
and he simply stretches it from one end
of the train to the other and that way
he measures the length of the train and
let's say he finds
that the train is 210 meters long
good okay that's all perfectly
straightforward
let's now imagine that our second
character gracie
she is on the platform so from her view
the train is in motion so she has to use
another approach to measure the length
of the train right
she can't really pull out her tape
measure and measure the length of the
train because the train's rushing by
right so that's
not a way that she's going to measure
the train's length instead she does
something
more clever let's assume that she knows
the train speed let's also assume that
she has a stopwatch
what she can do is the following she'll
start
the stopwatch just as the front of the
train
is passing her she will stop the watch
as the rear of the train passes her so
she knows
how long it took for the train to pass
by her
she knows the speed of the train and she
simply multiplies
them together she multiplies velocity
times time
to get the length of the train right so
let's
see her do that
there she is on the platform
she has her stopwatch handy
the front of the train goes by boom she
starts
the watch going when the rear of the
train
passes her boom she stops the watch
she gets the elapsed time in this case
5.9 seconds
she multiplies it by the known speed of
the train
in order to get the train's length
that's her
approach now here is the remarkable fact
the two approaches george's approach
where he simply used a tape measure
gracie's approach where she uses this
watch and the known speed of the train
they
yield different answers right
so if you multiply this out just in this
particular example
30 times 5.9 177 meters
numbers i should say which i've made up
just to illustrate the point which is
that
gracie has gotten a shorter length of
the train compared
to george now at first sight
that is hugely surprising right
but the question is does this
actually puzzle george assuming
that george has taken the
discussion that we've already had to
heart and he fully knows
about time dilation with the notion of
time dilation does the discrepancy
in the length of the train from his
perspective and from gracie's
perspective does it puzzle him
and the answer is no because from
george's perspective here's what he says
he says look
i understand gracie's approach she's
using
length equals speed or velocity
times elapsed time but i also
know that gracie from my perspective
right i'm now george
gracie from my perspective is in motion
clocks in motion tick off time
at a slower rate if a clock is ticking
off time at a slower rate
it'll show less elapsed time and
therefore
it will in that multiplication yield a
shorter
length so from that point of view george
understands why it is that gracie got
a shorter length but the question
remains
who is right is the length of the train
210 meters as george
says that it is or is the length of the
train 177 meters
as gracie says that it is
now you can probably guess
the answer to the question of who is
right based on
what we have discussed so far the answer
is
they are both right the answer is
length itself is a concept that we need
to rethink
we normally think about length as the
length of an
object but in fact the length of an
object depends on its speed when
you measure it now where does that
idea really come from that idea comes
from
the following fact that we have
emphasized repeatedly
simultaneity is in the eye of the
beholder right
now to measure the length of an object
you need to measure its front and its
rear
simultaneously at the same moment
now if two observers have different
notions of simultaneity
they will therefore have a different
notion of the length
of an object no single result is solely
right
no result is wrong they're all equally
good now having said that
just a little bit of language we
generally call
the length of an object when you measure
it when you are
at rest relative to the object as george
is in the case of the train
we call that the rest length of
the train we call it the proper length
of the train but that just calls out a
particular
perspective the perspective of somebody
not moving relative to the object
but fundamentally you can measure the
length of an object when it has any
speed
relative to you and you will get a
different answer
depending upon the speed of the object
so the general conclusion then that we
are reaching is that
moving objects are shortened along the
direction
of their motion and let me stress that
it's
only along the direction of motion that
the
object will appear shorter
the height of the object will not change
at all and a little tiny argument can
establish that for instance if you were
to imagine that the train were going
into a tunnel
right and let's say it just barely fits
now if it were the case that from one
person's perspective
the height of an object not in the
direction of motion if that were
to change let's say i were to say that
the height of objects gets smaller
well then from my perspective on the
train the tunnel will be smaller
i won't be able to fit i should smash
into it right
from the perspective of someone who's on
the tunnel
it'll be the train that will be shrunk
in that direction
and so it will fit now however weird
relativity is it can't be the case
that in one person's perspective there's
a crash
of the train into a tunnel and from
another
person's perspective there's not a crash
that would really be a contradiction
that would be a paradox
that can't happen and therefore we learn
that it can't be the case
that dimensions that are perpendicular
to the direction of motion
they are not changed at all they stay
fixed
and so we describe the
shortening of an object along the
direction of motion
we call that length contraction or we
call that
the rent contraction that is the
language that we used
and let's take a look at a simple
example of that so here
is a case where we're looking at a new
york city taxi cab
moving pretty quickly along and along
the direction of motion
the taxi cab is shrunken it is shorter
along that direction
than it would be when it is at rest
so let's take a look at a
demonstration which will give you a feel
for
the amount by which an object appears
shrunken along its direction of motion
when you are looking at it
so this little demonstration here allows
you to
pick the speed of this taxi cab as it's
rushing
by you and again get a feel for this in
your bones
as the speed creeps up not much of an
effect
on its length but when the speed
approaches the speed of light
the object gets ever shortened
along the direction of motion
now you can ask yourself a
natural question at this stage which is
does the object in motion really shrink
and if it does like what's the force
that's squeezing
on it now that's a natural question but
it's
pretty loosely phrased because the main
point
that we have come to is that the notion
of
length itself the notion of length
itself requires
a notion of simultaneity because again
if you're measuring the length of an
object
in motion if you first say measure the
back
of the object and the object moves and
then you measure its front let's say i'm
measuring the length of a fish in a pond
right if it's swimming along and i first
measure
its tail and i let the fish swim and
then i measure
its nose well i'll get a different
length than i would if i measured
the front and the back the nose and the
tail at the same moment
so it's critical in talking about the
length of an object to commit to a
notion of
simultaneity and that requires
choosing a frame of reference because
observers in motion don't agree in what
happens at the same
moment in time and because of that
different vantage points differ
regarding what happens at the same
moment
we come to the conclusion that an object
in motion has a length
that depends upon its speed because its
speed
determines the degree of the lack of
simultaneity
between two perspectives so if we ask
the question again
do objects in motion shrink the best
answer i can give you is
yes and no it definitely is the case
that an object in motion has a length
from my perspective that is shorter than
when
that object is at rest but it's not as
though someone has come
in with a vice and squeeze crush the
object down
it simply is that the old idea that
there's a universal notion of the length
of
an object needs to be updated by
relativity
the length of an object depends upon its
speed
when you measure it and that is a
surprising result
the length of an object depends on
its speed now give you a couple other
little examples
of that to have in mind
and both of these examples
make use of the idea that we discussed
earlier the
relationship between observing something
and measuring
something so back then i described how
we're
mostly focused upon reality
so we don't really care so much about
human perception we care more about
what happened in the world to be
responsible
for what we see but sometimes it's kind
of fun to
look at what we literally would see if
some of the effects of relativity were
visible to us
and in this example here we are now
going to look at a taxi cab
but done more precisely so this is how a
rushing taxi cab
would literally look if you could see it
rushing by at high speed
notice that the taxi cab appears kind of
twisted right in the last frames of that
little video we could see the whole
back bumper of the taxi cab even though
ordinarily if a taxi cab was rushing by
us we wouldn't be able to see the whole
bumper we'd only see the part that was
nearest to us
the reason for that is a little bit
complicated it makes use of the fact
that when we look at something we are
seeing light from the object light takes
different amounts of time to reach us
from different points on a
three-dimensional object because those
three-dimensional points are a different
distance from our eye
if you take that into account then that
little video gives you
a really good sense of what it would be
like to literally
see an object rushing by near the speed
of light second example
puts us inside the taxi cab itself
shows us what it would be like to look
out the window of a taxicab that's
rushing through a city near the speed of
light
and as you can see the world around you
not only does it have the
length contraction that we've described
if you take into account
the finite light travel time the
differences from one point to another
you see that
space has a kind of warp distorted
curved look the world around you seems
to be curving in
around you when your speed approaches
the speed of light so again if
you could find a taxi that
could travel near the speed of light and
if you had really good eyes
so you could actually see the world
around you as it was rushing by you at
very high speed
that is what you would see so these are
some
very strange effects
that the constant speed of light has
on the nature of space but they all
follow directly from the analysis that
we've already done
with time so once you know that time has
weird features
you know that space must have weird
features too
in order that in tandem they can keep
the speed of light constant
we understand now the resolution of the
poll in the barn paradox at least
qualitatively
let's now take a look at the numbers the
mathematical details which will allow us
to
reconcile these two apparently
contradictory perspectives so
what we want to do is to first take a
look say at the perspective of team barn
we know that they say that the poll fits
and what we want to work out is how
does team pole come to a different
conclusion
from the perspective of team barn team
barn is like i can't understand how they
came to this different conclusion they
said the poll doesn't fit
let's understand mathematically how it
is that they
resolve that headache that conundrum and
they do
finally understand this claim of team
poll
that doesn't fit so to set this up let's
start by considering the perspective
of team barn let's try to figure out
how they make sense of the
strange conclusion that they hear from
team pole and to do that let's
record a little data to begin with so
according to
team barn the pole is rushing by
at 12 13 the speed of light pretty
fast and remember that the pole its rest
length
we are told is equal to
15 feet okay good now
let's draw a little picture of this so
we know what we are talking about
we have the pole it's
rushing along and it's
rushing along in this direction
to my left as i face the board
and the speed of this guy
is at v equals 12 13 c
okay now what does this mean from the
perspective
of clocks that are being carried by the
pole
from the barn's perspective right so
let's imagine
that the pole has clocks at the front
and the back
and let me draw those for good measure
so let's say we have a clock here
and we have a clock over here and we
know that
the clocks from the barn's perspective
will not be
in sync with one another right so if the
pole is rushing this way
we know that the leading clocks will lag
behind in time they will be
late right and let's calculate how far
behind
this clock is relative to the clock at
the rear
and that we know how to calculate the
time difference so the difference
between those two clocks
this little formula we take v times
the distance between those two clocks
divided by c
squared so plugging in the data that we
have at hand
velocity is equal to 12 over 13c
we've got the distance between those
clocks and again this formula is the
distance as viewed
in the frame whose clocks were
discussing so this will be
15 feet and since we're using feet of
course we'll take
c to be one foot
per nanosecond squared
so here we have our answer 12 times 15
is 180 divided by
13 nanoseconds
and this is about 13.8
nanoseconds so what that means is when
team barn
looks at these clocks if for instance
this clock over here on the right
is reading 13.8 nanoseconds
then this clock over here on the left
will be
13.8 nanoseconds behind so it will be
reading zero
when this one's reading 13.8 nanoseconds
now
qualitatively what does that mean
qualitatively that means that according
to
team barn team poll is assessing the
location
of the rear of the pole before it
assesses
the location of the front of the pole
that means that the pole moves between
when
the rear position is assessed and when
the front position is assessed
and that's why the front has time to get
out of the barn
according to team barn that is why
according to team barn
team poll comes to this weird conclusion
that the poll doesn't fit
now let's make that quantitative we know
that there's this 13.8 nanosecond
difference in the reading of the clocks
that is not
the time difference according to team
barn
regarding when the front and the rear
are assessed because of course this
clock needs to catch up to that one
13.8 nanoseconds but it's ticking off
time slowly because it's a clock in
motion according to team barn
so if we calculate gamma in this case
which will allow us to convert that time
difference into the time difference
according to team barn what is gamma in
this case
well again 1 over the square root of 1
minus 12 over 13
squared and if you work that out that
gives us a nice answer of 13
over 5. so what team barn says is
you take this 13.8 nanosecond difference
in the clock readings
and you multiply it by 13 over 5 to
figure out how
long after the assessment of the rear of
the pole
will the front of the pole's position be
assessed by those in team pole
so let's do that so if we take 13 over 5
times the difference in the clock
readings and let me just write that
as 12 over 13
c times 15 feet
divided by 1 foot per nanosecond
just to get our full answer so the 13s
go away
the 5 goes into 15 3 so this gives
us 36 nanoseconds
so according to team barn 36 nanoseconds
after the rear of the polls position is
assessed
the front of the polls position will be
assessed by those in team poll
how far does the poll move between those
two assessments
well that's just velocity times time
right so we have
36 nanoseconds how fast is this pole
traveling well it's going 12 13 c
so that's 12 13 foot per nanosecond
using our usual formulation and
therefore
if you just plug in the numbers and
calculate this out you will get
33.23
feet approximately as how far the pole
is going to move between the assessment
of its rear location and the assessment
of its front location
so what does this mean let's draw a
couple of pictures to see
what this implies for the measurement of
the position of the pole
so let's draw a little schematic
representation
of the barn and for good measure let's
make some doors so that the pole
can get inside of the barn and now let's
look at the motion
of the pole from the barn's perspective
so according to the barn
folks gracie and her friends they say
that the poll fits inside period end of
story but they also recognize
that the clocks that are attached to the
pole are not in sync
relative to each other and they say that
the pole people first
measure the location of the rear of the
pole and only later
measure the location of the front and
we've calculated
that there's a 36 nanosecond
time difference between when the rear
and the front are measured which means
the pole moves during that interval in
fact we've calculated how far
it moves the distance between
these two locations we calculated that
as
33.23
feet so that's how far the pole moves
between when the rear of
it is measured and when the front of it
is measured so of course
the pole doesn't fit inside the barn
during that interval
it travels this distance so the front of
the pole gets outside of the barn
so in this way team barn is
able to clear their headache right
they didn't need any excedrin they
didn't need any advil they just did a
little calculation
and in that calculation they recognize
that team pole first assesses the rear
location
and only later assesses the front and by
the time they assess the location of the
front
it has slipped outside of the barn
that's how team barn
explains this weird sounding conclusion
according to team pole that the pole
does not
fit inside so that gives us
our nice explanation according to team
barn
of the weird conclusion of team poll
good now what we want to do is the same
kind of analysis but from the
perspective of
team poll we want to understand
mathematically
how it is that team poll can explain
the observations the conclusions the
claims of team barn
that the poll does fit and we can do
really just the same calculation but
it's worth
doing a second time same essential ideas
but now let's look at this from the
perspective
of team paul and try to understand
how team paul explains this
headache inducing claim that team barn
is saying
where the team barn says the poll fits
team paul says how could they say that
and we want to understand how they
clear that conundrum by analyzing clocks
in the barn frame from their own
perspective
and of course the key idea will be that
according to
team paul the clocks
in the barn frame of reference
are not in sync
even though the barn folks
say that those clocks are in sync right
so just so we can
get a picture of what's going on here if
we
draw a little schematic here of the barn
so the barn has clocks all along its
length let's just
draw the clock say at one
end and the other and according to
team pole it is the barn that is rushing
along at a speed v
in this direction and that
speed v is equal to 12
13 of the speed of light
and since the barn is rushing in that
direction according to team poll this is
then
a leading clock it's in the direction of
the motion leading clocks lag
behind they are late so this clock will
lag behind
this clock and we can calculate how much
it will lag behind
in order to understand the reasoning of
team barn
from team pole's perspective so what is
the time difference between those clocks
well we know what to do we take the
velocity which is 12
13 c we multiply it by
the distance between the clocks from the
perspective of
team barn that's the way this formula
works that is
10 feet and we divide through by c
squared
which is just one foot per nanosecond in
the approximation that we are using
so this gives us 120
divided by 13 nanoseconds and if you
just
work that out that's approximately 9.2
nanosecond difference between these two
clocks what that means
is according to team poll if say this
clock is reading
12 noon then this guy over here will be
lagging behind
and will be 12 noon minus
9.2 nanoseconds
so qualitatively what this means is
according to team poll team barn is
first going to assess the location of
the front of the pole
say they will claim it's inside at 12
noon
and then they will allow some time to
elapse before this clock catches up to
12
noon and in that interval the barn will
move to the right
allowing the rear of the pole to slip
inside
and that's why according to team pole
team barn
says that the front and the rear of the
polar inside at the same moment
whereas from team pole's perspective
those are not the same moment
because the clocks in the barn are not
in sync
now we can make that quantitative of
course by figuring out
according to team poll how long will it
take for this clock
to catch up to 12 noon it's not 9.2
nanoseconds because clocks in the barn
frame of reference are ticking off time
slowly according to team poll
so we have to multiply that 9.2
nanoseconds by gamma
to get the amount of time that will
lapse according to team poll
between when those two clocks when i
should say
this clock catches up to 12 noon so
let's do that what is gamma
gamma is 1 over the square root of 1
minus 12
over 13 squared
1 minus v over c squared work that out
that is 13
over 5. so now if you allow me i'm just
going to take that 13 over 5
and multiply it by the time difference
that we
calculated above so if you don't mind
i'm just going to do it right over here
13 over 5
times 120 over 13.
13s cancel 5 into 120
24 so that gives us 24
nanoseconds so again according to team
paul
the assessment of the front and the rear
of the pole happened 24
nanoseconds apart that is this clock and
this clock
differ from one another and it takes 24
nanoseconds
for this clock to catch up to 12 noon
now in that interval
the barn is moving over to the right how
far does it move well that's just
velocity times time
so we have 12 over 13 c
so let's do that 12 13 feet per
nanosecond
multiplied by that 24 nanosecond
time difference and if you just
calculate that out it comes to about
approximately 22
feet so according to team pole the barn
is moving
22.2 feet between
the measurements of whether the front
and rear
of the pole are inside namely more
precisely it is moving 22.2 feet between
when this clock
and this clock have the same reading so
we can see what that
implies by drawing a diagram similar to
the one that we had over here
but now this is from the perspective of
team paul
let's draw a version of the barn
and let me as before
give some doors for this pole to come
inside
and from the perspective of team poll
what we therefore have learned
is the following from their view
the poll does not fit inside
and again that's the end of the story
according to team paul but team pole
also recognizes what we have now
calculated which is that the clocks
in team barn are not in sync with one
another
so according to team poll what happens
is the barn folks
first assess the location of this end
of the pole they say it's inside but
then they
wait 24 nanoseconds
before they assess the location of that
side
of the pole so let me just draw that so
imagine that we now look at this
situation 24 nanoseconds later so let me
draw another schematic of the barn now
according to team pole
the barn has moved in those 24
nanoseconds which means
that even though according to team pole
this end of the poll did not fit inside
the barn at the same moment
as that end of the poll they recognize
that according to team barn they do fit
because according to team barn what
happens is
they wait 24 nanoseconds later according
to team pole the barn moves over we've
calculated how far that is
how far was that ah that's 22 feet so
let me just record that for good measure
so if i draw a little dotted line here a
little dotted line over here
this now is 22.2 feet so clearly
this diagram is not to scale but the
idea is correct
so according to team paul what happens
is the barn
moves over 22.2 feet
between when team barn assesses this
location and that location and then of
course
according to team barn the pole will fit
inside it's not measuring according to
team paul the front and the rear at the
same moment whereas of course
according to team barn this moment and
this moment
are the same moment according to team
pull
they are not the same moment the
relativity of simultaneity
coming back with the vengeance so that
is the explanation according
to team paul of how it is
that team barn comes to this weird
conclusion
that the pole fits inside whereas they
know that it doesn't fit inside both
of these pictures are absolutely correct
they're just two different perspectives
that allow us to understand
how it is that not only do these two
frames of reference come to a different
conclusion
as to whether or not the poll fits
inside but we now also
understand how each team understands
the other team's claim even though they
don't agree with it again coming from
the relativity of simultaneity
so that's the mathematics behind this
way of resolving the apparent paradox
of the pole in the barn what we want to
do now is to get
some feeling for these ideas by working
with some demonstrations which are good
to play around
with these things on your own and that's
what these
demonstrations are for so let's
take a look quickly at one but you
should study this in more
detail this is very similar to the
demonstration that we had earlier
except now you will note that it's
adorned with a little bit of extra
detail
so we now have doors on the barn
one moment in time from the perspective
of the barn
but not one moment in time from the
perspective of the poll and you know
that because
there's going to be a flash i should
have said that when it was going watch
for the flash and again do this on your
own
the flash is at one moment in time from
the polls perspective the poll says
that and that those are same moment in
time from the polls perspective
very different moments in time from the
barnes perspective
and similarly you should work on the
poll perspective two
where you'll see again the relativity of
simultaneity but now in mathematical
form
fully explains this poll in the barn
paradox
the twin paradox is the most famous
of all paradoxes in the special theory
of relativity
but before we get into it let me just
stress the most
important point there are no paradoxes
as i said earlier in special relativity
if there were the theory would collapse
there are however situations where it
seems like there's a paradox it seems
like we have
two perspectives that we can't somehow
meld
together into a coherent story but that
generally means we have to think the
situation through
with detail think it through with
our understanding of the essential
physics and when we do that
all paradoxes fall to the side the same
will happen here
okay let's set it up the paradox or the
seeming paradox will involve
a couple of characters they're twins
george
and gracie and the scenario is one that
may have occurred to you in our earlier
discussion of
time dilation and space travel because
we are going to
imagine in this case that gracie goes
into a spaceship
she travels out into space we're going
to have her go pretty fast
she's going to turn around and come back
here
is the issue from george's perspective
stay at home george on earth looking at
gracie from his perspective he knows how
time works in special relativity he says
that her clock
must be running slow so that when she
comes back
he will say that he will be older
not as much time will have elapsed on
her slow
moving clock compared to him
gracie however she looks back at george
and she says to herself look i
understand
special relativity too and it's george
from my perspective that's moving
i'm stationary and therefore it's his
clock that's ticking off time
slowly so when i return
it should be the case that i gracie am
older
because less time will have elapsed on
george's
clock that is the issue let's
see that in visual form
so here is the question there is
george first character and let's bring
in his twin
these are fraternal twins gracie she
gets into her spaceship
and we're going to send her off into
space
so let's do that and let's say she's
going fast
so there really will be some kind of
significant time dilation going on here
she goes off into space she's going to
reach some point that we will call p the
turnaround point
and she will then come back okay so
then the question that we are faced is
when these two guys compare
the amount of time that has elapsed
according to each will it be the case
that george is older than gracie will
his clock have ticked off more time will
it be the case
on the other hand that it is
gracie that is older will it be that
more time
has ticked off on her clock or
you could even imagine a resolution that
puts these two together
maybe it's the case that each of them
will have aged
each will be the same age as the other
when they return that is the question
we want to figure out which of those
three scenarios is correct
to resolve this seeming paradox that
each
says that the other's clock must be
ticking slowly
each therefore says that they should be
older
okay so i'm going to
offer you some resolution to this
paradox
the deep question is who is right which
of these scenarios is correct now you
might
guess that they are both right because
that has been
often times what we have encountered so
far in special relativity
each perspective is right and you just
have to reconcile them
with your understanding of how special
relativity works
so that's a natural guess but that guess
will
not fly in this case that will not work
because
at the end of the journey right george
and gracie are
together right so they can face one
another they can be
standing right next to each other in
fact they can even
go into the same frame of reference and
there can no longer be
any mismatch in their observations at
that point
one cannot look at the other and say
that you are older
and the other looks at the other person
says you are older that's
a contradiction that's a paradox that
can't happen so we cannot
rely upon the kind of resolution that we
have found earlier
somebody here is right somebody here is
wrong
how do we figure out which well
i am going to give you the answer it is
gracie
who turns out to be younger
george turns out to be older and i'm
going to give you
three explanations for that let me start
with
explanation number one which is a simple
explanation
that really cuts to the heart of the
matter
where does the contradiction come from
where does the apparent paradox come
from
it comes from george saying that he
can be viewed as at rest gracie moving
therefore her clock ticks off time
slowly and
of course gracie can say i
am stationary and it's george who's
moving and therefore i can claim that
it's his clock that is taking off time
more slowly is that valid
in this situation well remember
the only time that you can claim to be
at rest and the rest
of the world is moving by you is if you
are going
at constant velocity constant speed
in a fixed direction that is
manifestly not true in this case
for gracie gracie going out into space
and then
coming back she has to turn around and
when she turns around
she has to accelerate she slows down and
then she speeds back
up to get back to george on earth
she feels that acceleration she knows
that she is moving
she is no longer moving at constant
velocity
she is no longer justified in saying
that she is at rest
and the rest of the world is moving by
her so her
perspective her reasoning is
negated by the fact that she is
accelerating
she is not in an inertial frame of
reference
throughout the whole version of this
journey
and therefore we cannot trust her
conclusion
george on the other hand is in an
inertial frame
he is at rest on earth's surface he
does not move subject to the issues of
whether earth surface is an inertial
frame but those are the
complexities that we are not worrying
about for the discussion we are having
george's perspective therefore is valid
he
is constant velocity throughout this
entire
journey his conclusions are unassailable
they are
absolutely correct and he says
that gracie's clock is ticking off time
more slowly
and therefore when she returns he will
be older period end
of story that is the resolution
or i should say a resolution of the twin
paradox
we will come to other explanations as we
proceed
further with this deep scenario that
lets
us really sink our fingers into a lot of
the details that we have been developing
but as a first pass to this scenario
that is the explanation
gracie is accelerating for part of the
journey her perspective
therefore cannot be taken into account
she cannot say she's at rest george is
the only one who can say
that and his conclusion that he will be
older
is correct
perhaps the most famous equation in
all of physics is equals mc squared
it comes right out of the ideas that we
have been developing and i'd like to
first
give you a sense of where it comes from
just
motivating e equals m c squared for
those of you who are taking the
mathematical version of this course i
will do a full
derivation in short order but let's just
begin
with the ideas that lead us to the
possibility
that energy and mass e and m
might be deeply related they might have
some deep
connection that is ultimately embodied
in einstein's famous equation equals m c
squared now to do that i'm going to
start by
telling you a little story a story that
i like to call the
parable of the two jousters so
it's going to be a kind of joust but
different from the one that you might
have in mind we're going to have two
individuals
perfectly matched so they're going to be
on identical horses they'll have
identical
masses and they're going to hold a lance
but
not one that has a sharp end we're going
to imagine that there is a
large metal ball at the end of the lance
and the way this joust will work when
the two combatants
cross by each other just as they are
passing
each is going to lunge outward toward
the other
smashing their spherical balls together
trying to
knock the opponent over so let's take a
quick look at what that joust would look
like
this initially was meant to be another
george and gracie animation
but you know i contacted gracie she said
talk to my agent getting kind of diva
like so we have a new character
whose name is evil george so it's
george versus evil george there they
have their lances with the
metallic spheres they slam those into
each other
and because they are perfectly matched
we are assured that it will be a draw
a tie okay now
george takes a course in special
relativity
and he starts to think he says to
himself from my perspective i'm
stationary right
and therefore evil george is coming at
me and let's assume that this joust is
happening at very high
speeds the horses are moving near the
speed of light let's just say to be
dramatic
and george says to himself that means
evil george
is in motion from my view that means
evil george's
watch his clock is ticking off time more
slowly
that means from my perspective evil
george as he goes by he may be moving
quickly on his horse
but his movements will be slowed down
slow motion so george says this is going
to be a piece of cake
because as evil george goes by he's
going to lunge at me
so slowly that i will easily be able
to knock him over and win so that
is his view in his mind so just to
peer into georgia's perspective as he
thinks about this relativistically he
says
evil george's lance is approaching me
slowly so
i should win and yet he doesn't win it's
still a draw
so the question is what
was george leaving out evil george
thrust the lands at him slowly he should
be able to knock him over because he is
going to thrust it quickly
what has he left out well if you think
about it
the amount of impact that you receive
from a joust of this sort depends on two
things not one
it depends on the speed of the
lunge that's absolutely the case
but it also depends on the mass of the
sphere at the end
so what this tells us because it has to
be a draw again
right because it can't be that you
change your frame of reference
and you turn a draw into a win all
observers in space time agree on the
events
they may not agree on when and where
they happen but it can't be that from
one perspective it's a draw
from another perspective it's a win so
we know it still has to be a draw
so how can it be that evil george hits
george with the same
force even though the lance is going
slowly
it must be that the mass the mass of the
sphere
at the end of the lance must increase
to compensate for the slow push
that evil george uses so that
suggests to us that energy of motion
must be able to increase the mass of
an object and in fact we can go a little
bit further
we know the degree to which evil
george's lance has slowed down it's just
the
time dilation factor gamma that we have
encountered over and over again
so it must be the case that the mass
at the end of evil george's lance
increases by the same gamma factor
to precisely compensate for the slowdown
with which evil george is thrusting his
land so that
suggests to us that the mass of an
object
must depend upon its speed
the mass depends upon its speed and the
way it depends on the speed
is the mass that it has when it's at
rest multiplied
by the gamma factor now
that is a remarkable formula because
if we look at a little demo over here
look at what this formula is telling us
as
the velocity of an object gets larger
and larger this is telling us
that its mass becomes bigger and bigger
so you can play with this on your own of
course but there you see it
as the velocity of an object gets larger
its mass grows larger and larger
until as it approaches the speed of
light
the mass grows without bound
now this has a number of vital
consequences
number one we have spoken
a lot in our discussions
about the speed of light and implicitly
we've always been using the fact
that nothing can go faster than the
speed of light
but you may have recognized i have never
really established
that for you now i have
because if you think about it when you
try to speed up an object you've got to
push on it right
now if its mass gets larger because its
speed increases from your initial push
to get it go faster still you have to
push it harder
and harder and in fact as the speed
of the object approaches the speed of
light its mass gets bigger and bigger
and
bigger which means you need to push
harder and harder and harder to get it
to go faster still
until at this point you need an infinite
push to get it to go beyond
the speed of light no such thing as an
infinite push
and that establishes that the speed of
light is a speed limit
for any object that has mass the second
consequence here is that this result
strongly suggests that energy and mass
are interchangeable that you can take
the
energy of motion the energy of evil
george's motion
it turns into if you will the mass
of an object that he is carrying so this
interchangeability between energy and
mass is itself
pretty vital but let's take it one step
further still when an object is at rest
it still has mass of course m at v equal
to zero what we call the object's rest
mass so using the interchangeability
of mass and energy we're led to
anticipate that the object at rest still
also has energy so let me motivate
the formula for how much energy the
object
at rest has we know what the units
of energies are in traditional units you
may recall
it's kilograms times meters squared per
second squared
if you're not familiar with that formula
don't worry about it but this
is the unit within which energy
can be specified now mass
of course has units of kilograms so for
energy and mass to have the same units
we'd have to multiply mass by
something with the units of meter
squared per second squared meter squared
per second squared well meters per
second that's a speed
what speed would we multiply by in order
to have some universal way of
translating between energy and mass well
of course the speed involved
would be the speed of light so
this is one way of thinking about
einstein's
amazing realization that energy and mass
are interchangeable sort of like dollars
and euros
with the conversion factor between
energy and mass
being nothing but the speed of light
squared
e equals m c squared
thanks for coming along on this ride
into the
wondrous world of special relativity
these
wild ideas that come out of einstein's
thinking about
space and time matter and energy
let me leave you with just one thought
as you reflect back
on all of the material that we've
covered
all of the results that we have found
all of them fundamentally come from one
idea the constancy of the speed
of light right that is where the
relativity of
simultaneity came from remember forward
land and backward land it's the constant
speed of light
which makes it so that those on the
train and those on the platform do not
agree on what happens at the same moment
the constant speed of light
is what makes clocks tick off slowly
as they are moving by us right we use
the light clock again
constant speed of light as it travels
along
the double diagonal that is why
time ticks off slow when a clock is in
motion we then parlay that
into length contraction where lengths of
objects in motion appear
shortened along the direction of motion
and finally we've gone further and we've
come to this
stunning realization that energy and
mass
are interchangeable which is just to
show
that if you focus on an idea if you
focus on some new feature of the world
and are really able to think it through
to its logical conclusion sometimes
that results in a revolution in the way
that we think about things so go back to
the rest of the course review it
try to get a feel for these wondrous
ideas because special relativity is
truly
one of the crowning achievements of our
species